مشهد بدون شك يعني انتخابي بامتياز وهناك
الكثير الكثير من المؤيدين البعض يقول
انهم بالالاف هنا في هذا التجمع الانتخابي
في منطقه باي اوغلو او تقسيم كما نعرفها
في العالم العربي بعد نحو ساعه من الان
سيصل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ليلقي
خطابه الانتخابي الاخير هنا قبل ان يصلي
صلاه المغرب في ايه صوفيا المسجد الذي كان
يوما ما كنيسه يوما ما كان متحفا ومعروف
جدا في عالمنا العربي كان اليوم في
العمرانيه في الشق الاسيوي من اسطنبول وفي
سنجاب وسياتي الى تقسيم في القسم الاوروبي
بعد ساعه وبعد اقل من اربع ساعات سيدخل
الصمت الانتخابي حيز التنفيذ الى متى الى
التاسعه مساء يوم غد بعد انتهاء العمليه
الانتخابيه بالكامل اعتقد ان الموضوع
بالنسبه الى الاعلام العربي اسهل قليلا
دعني اوريك المنصه التي سيتحدث من عليها
الرئيس التركي بعد قليل عندما يصل هذه هي
المنصه وهؤلاء هم الحشود الذين يرافقون في
هذا الخطاب الانتخابي الاخير قبل ان دخول
الصمت الانتخابي حيز التنفيذ الاعلام
التركيه صور الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ولافتات والهتافات والاغاني الحماسيه
الوطنيه وتلك الخاصه بحزب العداله
والتنميه كل الوقت في هذا التجمع
الانتخابي يراهن الرئيس اردوغان على الحشد
بشكل اساسي كان قال اليوم تهم بايدن بانه
اصدر امرا بالاطاحه بالرئيس اردوغان من
خلال دعمه
والمعارضه واما الرئيس اردوغان فقال ايضا
في خطابه بانه بخصوص الاكراد نقطه مهمه
لانه في تحالف وهدى طائر حزب الدعوه الحره
يقول لهم هذا فرق كبير عن حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي الذي يؤيد المعارضه
مباني الصوره فيها انقره فاطمه
عفوا خالد هل تحدثني لا اسمعك نعم اسالك
انت ماذا عن انقره
نعم خالد اهلا بك واهلا بطارق يعني كما
بيطاهر كما تحدث طاهر بالفعل اجواء
الانتخابات تعم المدينه بشكل عام قبل قليل
كنا في احد الميادين الاساسيه في مركز
العاصمه انقره وكان هناك الناس يجتمعون
ويحتشدون كان هناك خيم انتخابيه باصات
انتخابيه اغاني وناس يعني يوزعون الاوراق
والبوسترز
للاحزاب التي يدعمونها ويبدون التصويت لها
غدا ولكن كنا نعلم بانك سيتواجد هنا في
ضريح اتاتورك من خلفي لذلك اتينا الى هنا
فورا ولكن للاسف منعنا من الدخول من خلفه
هنا يوجد ضريح اتاتورك في العاصمه انقره
لا نستطيع ان الناس يدخلون المناصرين
لكليشجار اوغلو يدخلون الى الداخل يحتجدون
من حوله ويتحدثون اليه كما نرى في البث
المباشر في القنوات التركيه ياتي هنا
ليختم رحلته الانتخابيه ويختم الجوله او
يعني الرح الانتخابيه الخاصه به هنا طبعا
كما ذكر ايضا طاهر بان الصمت الانتخابي
يبدا اليوم الساعه السادسه مساء يعني بعد
اقل من اربع ساعات من الان المنافسه على
اشدها وشرسه جدا يعني ما زال هناك
يعني ابتزاز مازال هناك
توتر وقلق يعم في الشارع وترقب خاصه من
الاجانب المقيمين واللاجئين خالد يعني
تحدثنا للكثير منهم ويتخوفون جدا مما
سيحدث من نتائج الانتخابات خصوصا ما ان
فازت المعارضه
بالرئاسه طبعا الناخبين او الناخبون
يصوتون غدا لمنصب الرئيس ولكن ليس فقط ذلك
يصوتون ايضا للنواب في البرلمان اذا يعني
من فاز من يفوز بمنصب الرئاسه ليس
بالضروري ان يفوز بالبرلمان والعكس صحيح
اذا المنافسه جدا شرسه ولكن اردوغان ربما
طاهر يصحح لهذه المعلومه اردوغان يعول على
ذلك يرغب بالفوز بالرئاسه ولا يمانع
البرلمان لانه يخطط بحسب الخبراء بان
يستقطب النواب الى جانبه ما بعد الفوز
بالرئاسه خلال فتره ما بين سته اشهر الى
سنه كما يتحدث معي الخبراء والمحللين في
الداخل التركي خالد استطلاعات الراي
متضاربه يعني هناك ارقام تظهرها بعض
الاستطلاعات تميل لصالح اردوغان ارقام
اخرى في استطلاعات ايضا من جهه او اخرى
تميل ايضا لاعطاء الارقام الاكبر لصالح
كليتش دور
في ظل هذه المنافسه الطاهره لاي مدى
اردوغان قادر من خلال هذه الخطاب الاخير
على الحشد الانصار على اقناع الشباب اقناع
على المراه اقناع كل الاطراف التي يمكن ان
تؤثر الان في يعني توجيه اصواتهم غدا في
مراكز الاقتراع لصالح
[موسيقى]
نعم اؤكد على ما قالته فاطمه خالد قبل ان
انتقل الى سؤالك المهم بالنسبه الى مقالته
فاطمه اردوغان اليوم في خطابه الانتخابي
تحدث صراحه وخاطب شعبه قائلا دعونا ننهي
هذه الانتخابات من الجوله الاولى دعونا
ننهيها اي بالتصويت له لاردوغان ومن ثم هو
قادر على ان يعتبر نفسه قادرا على
الاستقطاب الاحزاب الاخرى لا ننسى ان احمد
داوود اوغلو وعلي بابا تشان من قياداته
السابقه من قيادات حزب العداله والتنميه
من الذين انضموا الى المعارضه ويقول البعض
انه قد قد يكون قادرا على استقطابهم لاحقا
الى صفوفه من جديد ربما تحالف المعارضه
ايضا البعض ينظر اليه على انه متناقض جدا
في توجهاته وقد لا يستطيع السموم بغض
النظر عن من يربح في الرئاسيات او حتى لو
فازوا في البرلمانيات بالتالي تشكيل
الحكومه سيعتمد على التحالفات الانتخابيه
اذا هل يمكن ان يفوز ويخسر البرلمان نعم
والعكس صحيح قد يفوز بكري في الرئاسه
والاخرون الطرف الاخر يربح في البرلمان هو
يحاول ان يخاطب الشباب بالعوده الى سؤالك
يحاول ان يخاطب المراه يحاول ان يخاطب اهم
القضايا التي تعتبر من النواقص عند كل
عنده كما عند الطرف الاخر مثلا بالامس
سالت عن موضوع المحافظه والليبراليه احد
قاده حزب الشعب الجمهوري في لقاء معه يبث
لاحقا قال لي
عما تتحدثون عندما تقولون ان الطرف الاخر
هو المحافظ فقط قال لي انا قيادي في حزب
الشعب الجمهوري وانا محافظ اذا هناك
عناوين عريضه وبراقه اذا يستخدمها كل طرف
ولكن قد لا يستطيع الجذب فيها من حيث
خصوصيات المجتمع التركي طبعا يخاطب ان
يحاول ان يخاطب الشباب ولكنها نقطه ضعف
اساسيه كما تقول الكثير من المعلومات
والتحليلات عند اردوغ عند حزب العداله
والتنميه الشباب هناك اكثر من خمسه ملايين
ومئتي الف ناخذ يصوتون للمره الاولى لا
يعرفون غير اردوغان وغير حزب العداله
والتنميه في السلطه وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا قد
تكون تغيريه اما بقيه الامور المتعلقه
بالقضايا الشائكه فهي اقتصاديه بطبيعه
الحال او هويتيه متعلقه باي تركيا يريدون
تركيا الشرق او تركيا الغرب تركيا التابعه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه واوروبا او
تركيا التي لها علاقات جيده جدا مع روسيا
والصين كما اثر ان يكون او ان يذهب بهذا
الاتجاه اردوغان في الفتره الاخيره هذه
النقطه تحديدا اصبحت ماده اساسيه في
التنافس الانتخابي والتصريحات بين اردوغان
وكليتش دار مساله تدخلات الغربيه كليتش
دار يتهم موسكو بالتدخل في هذه الانتخابات
اردوغان من خلال تصريحه الاخير يتحدث عن
بايدن ويقول بانه اصدر امرا للاطاحه
بفاطمه هذه نقطه تحديدا الى اي مدى تؤثر
في توجهات الناخبين في تركيا بشكل عام وان
كان هناك ايضا اذا كانت الصوره تبدو اكبر
في انقره من خلال مشاهداتك
خالد من هذه الناحيه يعني طبعا روسيا كما
تعلم خرجت ونفت اي تدخل في الانتخابات
النخبون يعني لا يركزون كثيرا على هذه
المسائل وانما يركزون على ما يهمهم اكثر
من اقتصاد ومن معيشه ومن حريه تحدثوا
كثيرا
بالعدل والقضاء والحريه والحق والحقوق
بالمساواه وما الى ذلك طبعا الايديولوجيه
المختلفه والمتعمقه في حزب كل جدار اوغلو
تسبب مشكله له وتسبب قلق لدى الناخبين
ربما لهذا الحزب لانه يعني كما تعلمون لم
يكن المرشح الاول بالنسبه للطاوله
السداسيه كانوا يرغبون في احمد داوود
اوغلو او حتى في منصور ولكن
[موسيقى]
يرشح نفسه لرئاسه
الانتخابات هذه بالنسبه له فعلا مصيريه
وحاسمه لانه ماء خرج على المنصه وصافح
اردوغان وبارك له بالفوز في هذه الرئاسه
فبالتالي هو يوقع ورقه اعدامه السياسيه
بحسب بعض الخبراء والمحللين وفي المقابل
ايضا اردوغان هذه الانتخاب بالنسبه له
حاسمه ولا يريد الخساره فيها بالتالي يرى
المراقبين في الداخل هنا في تركيا خالد
بان هذه الانتخابات لن يتنازل عنها
الطرفين بسهوله يعني سيكون هناك هو هذا
تحديدا ما يسبب القلق والمخاوف سيكون هناك
مساعده من الجيش يعني كان في طلب ل60
الفرد من الجيش من قبل وزير الداخليه
وطبعا يحق لوزاره الداخليه ان تطلب من
الجيش ذلك ولكن فقط في حالات الارهاب
والطوارئ فيبقى السؤال هنا ما الذي سيحدث
ليله الانتخابات هذه الليله ليطلب وزير
الداخليه من الجيش ان يكونوا هنا ويساعدون
في الانتخابات وفي الامن وبالحديث عن
الامن والامان خالد يعني لاحظت هنا في
انقره في الميدان الذي كنا فيه سابقا وهنا
تجديد امني كبير جدا يعني ما ان نخرج
الكاميرا الا وينقضون علينا رجال الامن
السريين
ليفتشونا عن تصريحاتنا الصحفيه ويسالون
نحن من اين اتينا وفي اي توجه الى اي توجه
ننتمي والى وما الى ذلك من اسئله ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لكم
وفدت العربيه فاطمه فهد من انقره ومفرد
العربيه ايضا طاهر براكه من اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات